let's speak to a couple of other people
why not right I mean we're doing it we
might as well
let's talk to
how about Tom from Boston Tom from
Boston you're on the air
how's it going David it's going well
um so a couple weeks ago you had were
talking about needing like a Mass
deprogramming for you know the
conspiratorial thinkers and the hardcore
trumpers yeah
and then last week you mentioned that
you were reading going clear and it got
me thinking that I really don't think
that a mass d-programming is very likely
I agree with you I think I think we're
much more likely to see a Scientology
type situation where it's just slowly
chipped away at I think that it's
possible that if more of Trump's records
come out during this whole you know uh
case with his company
um that could do some damage but I
really think you're just gonna see all
of these groups that kind of came
together to support him splintered off
in yeah I mean the thing about that is
Scientology you know 74 million people
voted for Trump
um Scientology at its peak was a
fraction of a fraction of a fraction of
that very interesting we could be
talking about if we're just do if we're
doing that we could have to we might
have to work to wait two thousand years
right so I I think I guess that is true
that there are a lot of um a lot of
comparisons you can draw there are
pretty legendary con men
it's actually crazy in reading so what
what Tom is talking about is that I
mentioned I'm reading Lawrence Wright's
sort of profile of the history of
Scientology and L Ron Hubbard called
going clear and in reading it the way
people kind of got sucked in is very
trumpian L Ron Hubbard himself is very
trumpy and it's super interesting to
read because it's so analogous to Trump
trumpism
um yeah I mean I think I think you're
right nasty programming is difficult one
of the most efficient ways to mask the
program is with with a completely
authoritarian takeover right but that's
bad that's a bad way to do because all
you're really doing is you're
reprogramming exactly
right you're just reprogramming into
something else in an equally
authoritarian way so it's tough yeah as
I've said I don't really have a solution
but your solution likely is sensible
it'll just take a really really really
long time
unfortunately yeah I don't think we're I
don't think it's going to be a quick
thing no no by no means
all right well thanks and if you haven't
read Lawrence Wright's um
uh the looming Tower definitely give
that a read oh what's that one that's
his
um his history of Al Qaeda and the lead
up to 911. oh okay I'll check that out I
recently read his novel it's a Pulitzer
winner he wrote a novel a pandemic novel
called the end of October and I recently
read that as well yeah it's really you
have to check that out yeah he's quite
good he's very good very good all right
Tom thank you all right thank you very
good
um calls about books I mean guys what
more can you ask for right it's just an
incredible day here